[Musique]
1663 saviez-vous que le peuplement de la
réunion ne date que de 360 ans l'île
inhabitée était déjà connue des
navigateurs arabes lorsque les Européens
commencèrent à circuler dans la région
au début du 16e
siècle ce n'est qu'en 1638 que les
Français en prennent possession au nom
du roi Louis XII mais ne s'y installent
pas Madagascar est bien plus
attrayante l'île baptisée Bourbon est
d'ailleurs utilisée à plusieurs reprises
comme lieu d'exil pour punir certains
collant français de Fort Dauphin
cependant on les récupère à chaque fois
en bonne santé Louis paayen est le
premier à demander son transfert
volontaire dans l'île accompagné d'un
autre Français dont l'identité n'est pas
certaine ils arrivent le 10 novembre 663
jour de la Saint- Paul dans la baie
qu'il baptise du nom de l'apôtre ils
sont accompagnés de 10 malgaches 7 homme
et trois jeunes filles il s'instalent
peut-être à proximité de l'étan mais le
groupe se dispute et les malgages font
leur propre campement pour s'isoler et
c'est ainsi que 5 ans plus tard un
couple de malgage donne naissance à la
première fille née dans l'île
anneemous
1663 début du peuplement de la
[Musique]
Réunion